welcome back we're here with Oprah and
her newest book club pick and along with
Anthony ray Hinton he wrote the Sun does
shine how I found life and freedom on
death row and it is an incredible story
I like John's point where you talked
about reading or Norah talked about
reading in the book club where your mind
can go because your mind you married
Halle Berry yes then you dropped Halle
Berry for Sandra Bullock you and your
mind it was a good marriage then you
like then you played in Wimbledon yes
you were on the New York Yankees on your
mind
you did that because what mr. Anton I
needed to escape yeah to live on a 5x7
day in and day out 365 days a year is
unbearable and can anyone imagine if
you're there for something you know you
didn't do yeah that was worse so even
when there was a lawyer at one point who
offered you the opportunity to be able
to take the life sentence you said you
would rather die the life sentence would
mean that you were admitting you pass a
polygraph you had an alibi where you
wouldn't work
people were ready to say he was at work
and they didn't want to hear it and and
yet the first night you have here
freedom where did you spend the night I
spent it at luster house we stayed up to
about 2:00 in the morning and when they
went to bed I got in this bed that I
felt what's the sawfish bed that I ever
laid in could you like a soft thing miss
softly I didn't but this soft thing
about hour later became the nightmare to
me hmm
I couldn't see if I had to go in this
bathroom and lay on the floor and sleep
and my heart rate was just beating and I
said I know God didn't bring me out of
here let me die of a heart attack mm-hmm
and one once I ran into the bedroom I
didn't want to wake that stuff and his
wife up and I got went in the bathroom I
shut the door and as I sit on the floor
my heart rate starts going down
and I realized that I had lived in a
place so small for 30 years a 5x7
yes yeah that I wasn't used to being in
this open space and I just locked the
door and got in on all the feat of
positioning just what was it like when
you first walked out I know you called
the book the Sun does shine because
that's what you said when you first
walked out of being incarcerated for 30
years what was it like to be in that
world of an open space and sky and grass
and trees the first time it was
beautiful I couldn't believe it and in
my mind I kept saying is this a dream
because I had fantasized so much in my
mind and trying to escape and I kept
asking myself am i fantasize and now and
I looked up and the sun was shining on
me that day brighter than it was but
there's a funny part in the story about
you and Lester driving you're thinking
who is this white woman talking doors
tell us that the first time you were
there first time you're in the car
giving leaving prison oh he actually saw
where the first place you want to go and
I said I want you to take me where they
laid my mother body yeah I know she's
not there but I want to go and see what
they later and he's okay and I buck up
and I've seen him fidgeting with the
radio I'm thanking him trying to find a
radio station yeah and he was putting it
in now that I know address and as we
went down there they rolled this white
lady come on turn this off where he
couldn't take it in movie turn in 700
feet and he yes and he said that's GPS
he says she's in here
a lot change but he had told me a lot to
learn Brian said the world have changed
so much yeah Brian Stevenson says that
this is really about the evolution of
slavery that slavery becomes lynching
lynching becomes codified segregation
and now we're in an era of mass
incarceration and you end this book with
all the names of the people on death row
and I think that is especially poignant
because we all need to be reminded of
what this is it's not just you yeah
there are so many more like you
absolutely I often tell people and our
tobin's Winfrey
there's thousands upon thousands of
Anthony Rea Hinton in prison in this
country and I've learned that if you
don't have the money to have decent
defense
yeah capital punishment in capital can I
can I just say this when when Gayle was
reading the book cuz I'm like really
bright and I feel that way about for
everybody who's watching us and kaskus
why do I like mr. Hinton so much I don't
really like mr. Hinton so much I said
it's the first time we've been reminded
if somebody was the spirit of Mandela
spent 27 years in prison and came out
with no anger and bitterness right and
Oprah thank you so much the Sun does
shine